好 兩手盤整的時候
大家就會忽然覺得
好像沒信心了
但不要忘記
之前我們常常提到的
漲價概念
如果他們現在
反而是一個比較低位階的
不應該是
您要好好注意他的時間嗎
好 這邊來請教雲翔哥了
雲翔哥正在參加比賽
對 加油
幫雲翔哥加油
這個月底就見分效了
好 但是我們先來看
漲價概念股
尤其是矽晶圓
在這一波反彈
算是比較吃力的
但是他們也講了
不管長約或是現貨價都要漲價了
功率半導體也是
再來的話
所謂的SpaceX終於已經往上飛了
可是我們的低股位新概念股還滿低的
好 那先看一下
因為我覺得大盤還是要再關注一下
是
對 那目前來講
對 我就覺得比較黏
不過本來這樣子也符合我自己的這個看法
就是說我認為橫向走是一個比較具優勢的
因為你要直接越過這個
48000多
除非這個量就供到1.5兆
那今天剩下5000多億
不過這個應該剛剛那個
時空有講
對 這南部的問題嘛
對 那希望這個
南部沒什麼災情
大家每天趕快歸隊
好 你還是需要量
趕快放出來
對 要放出來 對
那基本上還是會比較安全
因為目前看起來是
優勢是這個
月限来讲它是已经往上
对 月限变往上了
那今天来讲因为刚好一个黑K
所以现在这个季线
目前还是没有站稳
那不过我觉得说
这个量有稍微起来
基本上横移慢慢的
还是可以站过去
那尽量来讲就是
在这样比较没有量的情况下
我自己会稍微避开一些
比较高价或者是全值
因为这个量不足的情况下
你这些高价股不容易推升
当然它的业绩
它的基本面要够好
確實如果今天漲幅
平常跑拉出來
還滿多是中低價
對 中低價 然後大概有業績
那如果可以找到說
它已經整理過後呢
在右邊產生一些底部形態
所以我等一下會大概講一些
就是像橫盤突破 最近有
那這個倒頭肩的這個形態
或WD
我覺得這些基本上
如果已經有完成了
那當然有多了一個
有所謂的一個支撐的一個力道
是 倒頭肩就是頭肩底的意思嗎
對 頭肩底 對 頭肩底
西晶園今天還滿強的
因为这个
环球金的董事长
对
那已经有谈到说
可能要涨价
所以涨价大概说
大概一成
大概10%起跳了
所以当然12寸
它是主要的一个阻力
所以12寸8寸6寸
基本上大概都有涨价的一个空间
那其实来讲就是说
等了很久
终于等到了
对
因为其实很多
当然它下面的这些下游都在涨
是
对
那其实这个我们讲说
这个MOSFI这一块
就是我们讲说功率元件
接近涨兩波了
第三波在10月份來講
也已經講說第三波
應該10月份會漲大概接近15%左右
所以也大概是
也等同是等於上下游這一塊
基本上全部都在動
因為我覺得合理
因為整個AI伺服器這一塊
需求量這麼大的情況下
當然這些都會用到
所以我倒覺得說
如果以這樣的一個看法來講
我倒覺得說
矽晶圓這一塊
一直延伸到所謂的功率元件
我倒覺得說可能都要稍微注意一下
對 那這一塊來講 對
大概我們大概有提了
新進院跟公路元件
我大概稍微整理出來
那主要新進院來講
當然是看這兩次 對
看環球晶再來就看他媽媽中美晶那環球晶基本上我覺得說他第二季出來還不錯大概有到7塊9那其實他六月份有一個認列
認列 試創的
對 可是第二季也認列的
這個股價的一個上升
也就同樣一支股票
一個認列損失一個
所以基本上等於是
這個完全是本業了
對 所以以本業來講我覺得還不錯
也等於有到他原本想要的一個估值
因為2026年的估值
大概估大概21塊多
所以看起來是有朝這個方向走
不過本益比還是比較高
那我倒覺得以這樣來講
我當然會去看她的媽媽
為什麼
因為對她來講
她的股本大概六十幾億
那她的股本是接近50億
那她本來就是她獲利
因為這樣她50%
所以她收益的部分
她都要稍微要等一半
要上交給她
所以你看就是說
基本上如果她就算9塊錢
她本益比才20倍為什麼
因为它才180几块
我觉得基本上它应该会慢慢往上拉近
因为这个距离有点远
那公立元件来讲
就是大家可能比较关注
像强茂 德威 这些MOSFIN
基本上当然这一块来讲
这是主要的一个
大家会看的一个部分
那他们的本益比大概落到大概28
对 益比大概在4块多到9块多
可是价格来讲
基本上也多到100多块到200多块
所以以这一块来讲就是说确实
它的业绩是有成长
从企业的营收来讲
看起来是YY跟MOM
基本上都是增长
那这个获利Q1跟Q3都是增长
所以都是一个成长
那我倒觉得说可能这一支
我可以跟大家来讲一下看一下
为什么
因为博胜这一支来讲
它是属于供利元件这一块
是
不过它比较偏向
它是一个IC设计
晶片的一个设计
那你可以发现说
它100多块的一个股价来讲
它的月营收
已经到历史新高
对 那另外来讲
就是它的一个营收的YY来讲
是63%左右
那EPS来讲就是今年已经到
上半年到大概3.5%左右
所以如果今年雇到10块钱
它的本益非常低
大概只有15倍
这个我们大家可以来看一下
我们先看一下这个矽晶源的部分
那中美金跟环球金
我觉得可以这样看
就是说因为环球金
本来是走一个很漂亮
上升轨道
那本来破了这个
我们讲说它是一个
强力工具的一个力量
那7月遇到这个大压力回来呢
刚好有遇到这个所谓的
扔这个6月的损失
所以一下来基本上
直接灌破了这个上升轨道
那我觉得这个基本上
就是比较不好的位置点
为什么
因为上升轨道现在本来是支撑
会变成压力
下来变成压力
所以变成说你在这里
有一个压力点来讲
就要等它再站回去
所谓的这个位置点来讲
对它来讲当然是
比較具有優勢
那中美金反倒你會發現說
它在這位置點來講
它根本沒有跌破
它的一個上升軌道線
因為它也沒有漲那麼快
對 沒有錯
那它的量基本上都維持它還不錯
所以我倒覺得說
以它今天來講
雖然它這位置點
可是它剛好就落點
落在這個上升軌道線下緣
同時又站上所謂的月季線
我覺得說這個是有個機會
至少可以拉到
這個上升軌道在上緣左右
在軌道內去兼操作
我覺得它是比較值得
好 中美金又回到軌道的下緣
可以留意
那在這個公路元件來講
就是大家可能會比較看強茂
因為大家著重在強茂這一塊
不過強茂它目前比較
不具優勢的地方
在說它的月線還是下彎
對 那我倒覺得說你可以等到它月線慢慢有一點翻揚也就是說慢慢如果說放一點量它基本上能夠當然如果能越過這個所謂的
150這個位置
也就是說
它目前來講
這也走一個橫向
是
那橫向
基本上你要走橫向的上緣
要越過
越過基本上
基本上這個上緣來講
比較有機會
所以我倒可以等一下這樣
那剛講的772來講
就為什麼會特別聊到它
就是說
基本上它在這一塊裡面
它AI伺服器它本來就有做
AI伺服器裡面的這個
相關的MOSFIT這塊
HGT的部分
那我覺得說目前來講
價位還是滿偏低的
所以這塊來講就是說
它的位置也很低耶
對 還滿低的
它目前來講說在這裡
它是一個橫行
對
那現在不一樣的地方說
它的月線是上氧
好
已經上氧
對
它的量也縮到只有幾百張了
對 可是今天稍微有
稍微供起來
不過我覺得說
量應該還要再放
那放過以後基本上如果能夠
現在站在這個所謂的
橫向整理的一個上緣
剛突破
如果突破能夠直接越過
這個所謂的一個季線的位置
我覺得它有極荒上風
好 這個量超
逃的時候三四千張
現在剩四百多張
可是因為它股本比較小
它業績很好
你會發現它在攻擊的時候
基本上力道會很強
它有可能是直接漲一路可能
所以這個我覺得可以等待期待
好 如果能夠再放量攻
股本小好拉
另外一塊當然講到SpaceX
每次都說投資馬斯克
是一種人種
就是說它的股票很難預測
就是我很多朋友
Space也很多買在150左右
那一波跌到100左右
基本上大家覺得說
這個怎麼回事
結果這一波也是很猛
從這裡大概整個
漲了大概快40%
等於拉到將近快140
現在135 136
那我倒覺得說
以它來講
今天有出一個新聞
就是說市場認為說
SpecX它的成長性
未來五年
這個是20倍
它的營收大概快21倍了
那輝達它估值是大概2.88倍
所以認為說它還超過輝達的7倍
馬斯克說這個預測是偏保守
對 偏保守
那我覺得基本上它會這樣談
當然說SpecX
你可以去看它的營收報告
確實是很好
對 那基本上
它今天又有推了一個
所謂大月底要首度營運
所謂的一個Starlink的V3
那這塊來講就所謂的一個
不管頻寬量跟它的這個
衛星的一個容量
基本上好像聽說達到10倍
所以對台灣的這些
當然Space相關的供應鏈來講
我覺得是一個利多
那這一塊來講當然很多說
森達科來講
當然是很直接的一個受惠者
因為他是做這個
所謂的一個射頻元件
這一塊
那另外來講說
台光電 滑通
这是属于PCB跟CCL部分
基本上除了台光电
是它的T2
其他都已经是T1
也就是说直接的供应者
那它本来是T2
它现在变成是
直接供应者变T1
所以目前来讲
对它来讲
这块的营收成长可能会很大
今年整年算快7块
可是这个估值来讲
国内的法人是把它估到明年
可能会拉到11到15块钱
好
所以明年是有成长
對 目前這種股價
大概今天90個來
基本上是還滿偏低的
好 先看老大 申達科
大家可能比較熟悉
還是申達科 華通之類型的公司
那申達科我覺得說
它滿有機會的原因是說
基本上剛好今天走了一個線型
是我們講說頭肩底
這應該叫頭肩底
頭肩底 對 這是左肩這是右肩 對不對這是頭部這是頭肩底部它跌到破你也現在很可憐對 那頭肩底部來講你就要用這個頸線的位置
對不對
往下拉到這個肩部的位置點
來去推出
他大概目前來講
2000目前他的一個
上面的一個壓力點
那目前來講一樣
就是說要越過頸線
他可能要拉一些量能突破以後
基本上有一些機會
那我覺得說
SPAC本來就是一直會持續
有一些
好 它是信仰
但是它看來也有角出營收
沒錯 沒錯
所以我覺得說
倒是這個大家可以關注一下
就是說未來如果說
剛好這個熱度又回到定位行
那我覺得這些來講
如果它越過頸線
那當然就有機會
好 先準備起來
大哥的動向很重要
介紹一下這一家運行
大家不要陌生
對 沒有錯
那這一家來講
就是以前大家可能認為說
它是車用
其實它現在目前來講
已經佔百分之快50
已經是電子產品
那電子產品裡面
它要有幾個比較重要的說
第一個來講就是藝能的部分
就AI伺服器裡面有一些藝能的設備
那D5衛星來講
這個就很重要
因為D5衛星它是剛切入這個
所謂的馬斯克這塊Spec X
那也已經是直接的供應鏈
所以它做的是什麼
做的是它的一個
我說電池殼
然後另外來講
對 機構件的部分
它都有做
然後散熱
散熱部分也有做
所以這一塊來講說
也是它增長的部分
那今天來講說
營收上半量已經達到2.85
年增是66%
所以拉得很高
那營收來講是創高以外
就是說它的年增率也很高
就是它的企業營收年增是66%
所以以前7月來講是年增大概30%
所以我覺得以這一塊來講
就是說如果今年是達到這個7塊錢
明年達到這個真的像法蘭說11塊以上
那基本上本益比真的非常偏低
因為現在才90塊
所以以這個來講我就認為說
目前走的是一個
基本上80期到90
本來就是一個長期的底部
是 這邊有攻
但是也跌回原點
對 跌回原點 一樣
7月剛好這一塊就是一個
大家從6、7月就是一個
大家都受難
從小行股都受難
那它一樣
它走的就是一個
所謂的我們講的頭肩底
最明顯的頭肩底
那這一塊頭肩也打上來
就有接近它所謂的
前波高點的位置
所以我倒也覺得說
慢慢它如果量
已經有慢慢攻起來
如果能夠量供錢
因為今天收了一個
很長的下影線
如果能夠直接越過頸線位置
我覺得說機會點是有的
是 跟大哥的長相類似
都是頭肩底
只是說他當然價位低很多
對 然後他的便利比也低很多
好 這邊非常謝謝雲翔哥的介紹
謝謝
好 亮縮盤
其實在雲翔哥的預測之內
但是他也希望放量
因為雲翔哥抓的
就是所謂的放量那一根
那現在正好是鎖定一些
看高做低 位階还很低
但底型差不多已经打好的股票
尤其是涨价概念股
如果今天细晶元扩散到功率元件
都确定到了年底
到了明年持续涨价
那现在位階低的
自然就是一个好的介入时间点
那至于低轨卫星
可能很多人都有点失去信心了
可是也可以看到大哥
声达科他已经打完了
所谓的头肩底的这个形态了
也介绍了里面的新兵
给大家认识
如果SpaceX继续升空的话
这类型比较低的
有放量的时候
我们一定要掌握起来
今天非常谢谢三位的来源来到现场
今天的量能比较低
南部再放假
希望大家出入都是一切平安的
当然在这个时间点
在家研究股票也是一个不错的选项
因为现在正在沉淀就等突破
那也希望今天的理财杂安秀
对您投资有帮助
明天再会了
拜拜